now there is good news in all of this
and tonight it's that the coronavirus
brought out the resiliency in a teenager
with las vegas ties who's now making a
difference
yeah he has created something called
covet candies
and says he is really trying to help as
many people as he can
sasha loftus joining us now live tonight
to share more on his mission
sasha
[Music]
denise and brian anyone who has
contracted kovit 19 knows it can be a
scary and really out of control
experience
the teenager i spoke with tonight says
that he knows that
all too well he was down for a while
with the virus but
now he's turned his recovery process
into real change
within you know two weeks we were all
taken out hudson hale
knows what it's like to cope with
covid19
i don't wish that anyone else would you
know or
would have to go through it um because
obviously it was not an enjoyable
experience
his entire family contracted the virus
earlier this year
and his road to recovery sparked an
effort to make a real change
i really decided that i wanted to do
something to help in any way that i
could
at just 17 years old the las vegas
partnered with fellow high schooler ryan
westcott
to create covet candies i just started
doodling a ton
and just kind of creating ideas and kind
of figuring out what works what doesn't
work
the sweet treats which model the
infamous covet germ
come in a package decorated with hales
designs
the money from each bag sold goes
directly to
several virus relief organizations they
kind of split up the money
and target you know certain people and
families
who are you know who have food
insecurity job insecurity
they've already raised over 16 thousand
dollars
which is pretty extraordinary but hale
says he's just
happy to give back it feels nice just to
kind of know that i'm creating something
that can help others
and he won't stop his efforts to bring
hope and happiness
to everyone all suffering is temporary
now each bag of covid candies is 12
again all the proceeds from each bag
purchase
goes to those virus relief funds other
than of course the small
cost to manufacture them if you'd like
more information or would like to buy a
bag we have a link to that on our
website
8newsnow.com for now reporting live in
las vegas sasha loftis
8 news now